- [Voiceover] Hey,
grammarians, today we're going
to be talking about
correlative conjunctions and
I know this this looks like
pretty ugly word, correlative,
like, it's kind of
complicated looking but,
let's break it down.
This co part comes from the Latin,
cum, meaning with or, together...
And relative, well, we know
that the word relative is, like,
your aunt or, your uncle or,
your cousin is a relative.
So, we're just going to say, that
just means relative or, related.
So, correlative conjunctions, there
we see it, definitionally
or, etymologically,
are related together in some way.
They're matched pairs;
they're a matching set.
And this just means that,
when you see one, it's
probably time to use the other.
In this video, we'll go
through five of my favorites.
So, either/or, is a good
pair to start off with.
And when you start a sentence
with either or, either,
I don't know how you say it.
It sets up the expectation
that you're going to have to
be choosing between two things,
so, we're going to say, or,
later in the sentence,
as in, what is reputed to
be Oscar Wilde's last words, either the
wallpaper goes, or I do.
The opposite of either/or is neither/nor.
So, either/or sets up this
choice between two options and
neither/nor rejects both options, so,
neither Jia nor Becca liked Howard.
And I recognize that I say neither and
some of you say neither and there's a
whole George Gershwin song about that but,
let's just chalk it up to
my Midwestern American accent, how 'bout?
♫ Either, either, neither, neither
♫ Let's learn about some conjunctions
♫ But oh, if we talk about the
both and you use and, and oh,
♫ If you learn to use conjunctions,
that is grand, oh yes ♫
Both Bigby and LaDoux
were career criminals.
Why we're using both to indicate a
connection between two things
and then we use and later in
the sentence to really firm that up.
As/so, is kind of an interesting one.
It's a little formal and it kind of
allows you to set up this relationship of
consequence, right, to say, if
one thing is happening then,
another thing happens
as a consequence, so...
As goes Kansas, so goes the nation.
So, you know, as one thing happens,
so must another thing happen, is
what this is trying to set up.
Whether and or, is
similar to either and or,
except it has a, kind of,
whiff of possibility about it.
Whether you like shrimp or
chocolate, there's certain to
be something for you at
the Veracruz food fair.
Right, because whether is, kind of,
setting up this possibility
between these two options and
it doesn't really matter
which one you choose.
It's just offering up possibilities.
And I would like to offer you the
possibility of checking out more of these
correlative conjunctions in our exercises.
So, stick around; you can learn anything.
David out.